[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جويريه اللي هي الملكه الافريقي فرع بحري
او
فيها كل الحب والاحترام واشبار الاشتواء
ولطف الرقيه
منيره معلمين
حتى لما تشوفيني الصباح
[موسيقى]
والله
العظيم بدون ملخصات عشان انا انقل منها كم
يه الساعه كم
ايام النشاطات
شديد
والله ما تكلمنا في المؤسسه حقه
[موسيقى]
يمكن انا امكانيات عاليه
عن المنتجات التي ام واب
واخوه لكن غني ما يقدر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بس للاسف الدوله
انا كنت بقرا خاص اهون من الحكومه لانه لو
كان حكومه ممكن يكون انا برجع البيت الوقت
ارتاح فيه عندي
المفروض انا
عشان
[تصفيق]
خلفيه عنها هي قالت برايم جهاز بتكون من
سته احرف بيكتب عربي وانجليزي ممكن
الرياضيات تمام فانا اخواتي تعمل شنو
الكتاب هو
انا بقول لها اي حاجه كله اخلاص بكل محبه
في ناس ما بدك ترتقيني البيت وترسل لك
الكتب دي منظمته شكرا
لكن انا في حاجات مثلا ما بقدر اكتبها في
حاجات ما بتكون عندي في الكتاب اول ناقصه
انت واختي ممرضه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سودانيه عندك
[موسيقى]
شهاده سودانيه
يا جماعه انا بكون
انت بتقول ايه
هي يعني
عندي على اخلي القرايه انت بتكون عارف
حاجه اسمها النقيب الداخل
العقل الباطن هو وسيله وفص ذهبيه لو احنا
عرفنا كيف نستفيد منها احنا بناء عبر
لا يفرق بين الحقيقه والخيال
بين الصح والغلط وما بصدق ادوات النبي
عشان كذا
من ابيض
فكره دي انه احنا على حاجات احنا نعملها
طريقه عشان يقرا عندنا الحاجه دي ممكن
نفصل لو في اي زول بيعرف زول ملتحي
اي زول
اللي هو دودي كوين ممكن يجيني وانا اقدر
اديهم
[تصفيق]
ممكن يجيب بعد ما فقره ان شاء الله
ومتوفره 24 ساعه في اليوم 60 دقيقه ساعه
وستين
[تصفيق]
لانه عشتها فيهم انا عايزه اساعد غيري في
الله انا كانوا بيقولوا لها ايه
الثالثه دي اي جهد فيها
اي جهد فيها
صحتك هتاخذ منها وقتك يتحدى ضيوف لو جبت
البيت انت ما تاكل
واحد يقول لي عشان صاحبي دخل علمي انا
بتكلم عن كل التين
والكلام ده او ما تحكي عشان صاحبتي علمي
المشكله
الفكره في انهي
مساله اتخاذ القرار اللي هي بيقول لها
الحكمه والقلب
والعينيه كلها نافعه يتخذ القرار ان
بيوديك للمصلحه البعيد انا لانه عيش
سودانيه
هتكون لها علاقه بالحلاقه
[موسيقى]
احنا طالعين السلمون تعال معنا هي لو فكرت
بعيده
هي حددت مصلحته لكن حققت مصلحه قريبه وحده
ثانيه
مخططه
انا حابه اقول حاجه في عشرين عشرين شهر 12
كنت واقفه في نفس القاعده وفي نفس المساله
وفي نفس المكان وقلت لهم
عشان قلت
[تصفيق]
الحياه رافضه فوسطه وقدره ما في زوج حيت
انا يا اختي حرفيا
[موسيقى]
عندك فرصه الحب هو عباره عن فرصه واستعداد
خلي في حياتك
ممكن
وبدقدق وانت تشوف
[تصفيق]
المسافه اللي انا اخت
رته اخترته بارابي
اللي هو
التخصص الان اخترته اخترته اللي هو
يعني منهم اغلب مساعد اختي في البدايه
خوفا عليه
انا بحبك ما احب الناس تحديته
حرفيا بحمد ربنا عليها ليل ونهار
غيري
مقعد بتمنى يسجده
[تصفيق]
مليانه السرطان حماد الله واياكم امراض
القلب والكلى مليانه
[موسيقى]
تحبي اخر يوم بسبب الامه وابوها منفصين او
واحد منهم توفى وغاده بالحياه
[موسيقى]
انا 25 السوداني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شفتوه
رغم المعاونه
[موسيقى]
الاهتمام اخر
احليهم تعيشوا معايا لحظات دي ونشوف
الفيديوهات وبعدين نرجع ونكمل الكلام
البسيطه الباقي ونشوف
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حرفيا اللحظات دي عمري ما انساها وحابه
اقول اني انا امتحنت في الظروف كاسه شديد
الوالده كانت مشهد خمسه
كانت بتقطع العمليات
راحت وما في مستشفى جديد عشان انا اقول
امشي ليها هي كانت
في القانون في السودان
في البخير
وتطلع منه اول
امك ما تاخذ متى انا عندي ام
[تصفيق]
حقيق اتمنى اكون بالبلوتو قدرت يعني اسرع
بصمه ولو كل واحد فيكم
واتمنى ان الامل
[تصفيق]
يا رب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]